la entrada al campo de goya guerra de
pintura el coche es ese juego en el que
la gente se dispara bolitas de pintura
cuesta cinco pesos y las balas de
pintura se venden por separado además de
la entrada por ejemplo la entrada y
cinco balas cuesta 8 pesos cuáles de las
siguientes opciones acerca de la
relación entre el precio y la cantidad
de municiones son verdaderas y me dan
todas estas opciones bien entonces vamos
a empezar considerando esta relación así
que digamos que sea
p igual al precio el precio total que
voy a pagar es decir la entrada más lo
que tenga que pagar por las balas y
también sabe igual al número de balas
número de balas que voy a comprar yo sé
que el precio va a ser una función del
número de balas por lo tanto puede hacer
una pequeña tablita en la que ponga el
número de balas
contra el precio que voy a pagar que
como dije es una función del número de
balas en sí entonces bien si no compro
ninguna balas y 40 balas entonces solo
tengo que pagar la entrada al campo de
goya me aburriría muchísimo pero lo
puedo hacer y me costaría 5 pesos así
que aquí con cero bolas pago 5 pesos y
si por el contrario lo que hago es
entrar y comprar cinco balas cumplo
cinco balas entonces el precio sube a 8
pesos bien entonces nosotros podríamos
pensar ahora en cuál es el incremento en
el precio por cada bala adicional que yo
compré para calcular eso voy a
preguntarme cuál es el cambio en el
precio con el cambio en la cantidad de
balas entonces por ejemplo aquí estoy
comprando cinco balas adicionales aquí
no compraba balas y aquí cumple cinco y
acá estoy pasando de pagar cinco pesos a
pagar ocho por lo tanto tengo un aumento
de tres de modo que el cambio en el
precio dividido entre el cambio en la
cantidad de balas
es igual a pues me cambio en la cantidad
de balas fue de 5 y me cambio en la
cantidad de precio que voy a pagar me
cambio en el precio perdón en la
cantidad de precio sino simplemente en
el precio es de 3 por lo tanto la tasa
de cambio de esta función sería de tres
quintos y eso es lo mismo que 0.6 0.60
si gustan porque quizás lo pensemos en
pesos así que 0.6 podría con estos datos
escribir ya la función explícita para el
precio podría decir que el precio
dependiendo de la cantidad de balas va a
ser igual a pues primero tengo que pagar
los cinco pesos de entrada al campo de
coche aunque no compre ninguna bala y
luego por cada bala que compre tengo que
pagar 0.6 pesos o 60 centavos es decir 5
más 0.6 por la cantidad de balas
y hagamos una pequeña gráfica para ver
cómo se ve esto aquí tengo mi eje
vertical que va a ser el precio que va a
representar el precio y por acá voy a
poner mi eje horizontal que va a
representar la cantidad de balas
entonces veamos aquí vamos a ponerle
incremento de 5 vamos a poner por acá el
por acá el 15 quizás
y aquí vamos a ponerle ser balas después
5 balas
por acá 10 balas quizás no sé
y bien como se ve la gráfica pues cuando
no tengo ninguna bala cuando tengo cero
balas estoy en cinco y cuando tengo
cinco balas tengo que pagar ocho pesos
por lo tanto mi gráfica pasaría más o
menos por aquí y como estoy asumiendo
que no hay cambio en el precio de las
balas dependiendo de la cantidad de
balas que compre esto debería ser una
línea recta y se vería algo así de hecho
esta función que escribí estar acá es
una función lineal por lo tanto describe
una línea recta ok
bueno ya que hicimos todo eso vamos a
pensar en las opciones que me dan la
relación entre el precio y la cantidad
de balas es proporcional pues eso no es
cierto porque si la relación fuera
proporcional el precio el precio debería
ser igual a una constante acá por el
número de balas pero entonces si no
tengo ninguna bala
aquí en cero entonces el precio debería
ser cero pero el precio cuando note no
pagó ninguna bala es de cinco pesos por
lo tanto esto no es cierto
la entrada con 10 balas cuesta 16 pesos
pues eso lo puedo checar a partir de la
función que escribí aquí simplemente
tengo que poner pues cuánto es el precio
por 10 balas pues sería 5 + 0.6 por 10
simplemente sustituir igual a 10 y esto
me da 0.6 por 16 5 es 11 por lo tanto el
precio con 10 balas debería ser de 11
pesos no de 16 por lo tanto esto tampoco
es cierto cuando la cantidad de balas
aumenta en 11 el precio aumenta en 6.60
veamos si la cantidad de balas aumenta
en 11 entonces podría escribir que el
cambio en la cantidad de balas uy eso
casi no se ve verdad
el cambio en la cantidad de balas
o más bien el cambio en el precio
dividido entre el cambio la cantidad de
balas debería ser igual a pues cuanto
siempre tiene que ser 0.6 0.6 pero en
este caso me están diciendo que el
cambio en la cantidad de balas es de 11
es de 11 así que algo entre 11 me tiene
que dar 0.6 entonces cuánto sería ese
algo veamos
tengo que 0.6 es igual a algo entre 11 y
entonces de aquí obtengo que 11 por 0.6
debe ser igual a ese algo y 11 por 0.6
es igual a 6.6 por lo tanto este signo
de interrogación vale 6.6 o 6 pesos con
60 centavos por lo tanto este de aquí si
es cierto
si aumento la cantidad de balas en 11
entonces el precio aumenta en 6 pesos
con 60 centavos y ahora me dicen que si
el eje x representa la cantidad de balas
la pendiente de la gráfica de la
relación es 5 tercios pues aquí tengo la
gráfica donde el eje x representa la
cantidad de balas y la pendiente que
recuerden es el alza entre el avance es
veamos pues aquí si aumente si aumente
la cantidad de balas el cambio en la
cantidad de balas es igual a 5 entonces
le corresponde un cambio en el precio de
cuánto
pues este aumento en la cantidad de
precio debe ser igual a 3 por lo tanto
la pendiente de esta recta la pendiente
de esta recta es 3 entre 5 y 153 por lo
tanto este tampoco es cierto y solo esta
tercera opción es la correcta